CBSsports proudly presents the PGA Tour
I love that CBS Sports and our friends
at the PGA Tour have been broadcasting
golf together on this very Network for
more than a half-century and we are
excited to announce that we will
continue this partnership through the
2030 season CBS will present about 19
events per season continuing as a tours
primary broadcast partner the 2023
CB in 2023 CBS will televise all FedEx
Cup playoff events and PGA Tour
Commissioner Jai Mata hey enjoins us now
how are you Jay thank you great to be
here waiting day 50 years is a lot of
history it sure is
what do you love about this partnership
well I'll tell you a quick story so 50
years and as we approach this right
cycle it was very clear given a set of
athletes that we have in the way that
the media world is changing that we want
to be with the partner that's going to
continue to evolve and innovate and
that's what CBS has demonstrated through
the years but when you talk about the
relationships in a relationship economy
our first kickoff meeting you had Shawn
McManus and David Burson there and
flying across the country was Jim Nantz
who wanted to be there to talk about how
important it was to himself and the team
and obviously to the company so a
long-standing partnership that has
yielded great results and it's a great
day for our players on the PGA Tour in
the LPGA Tour to know that CBS continues
to drive the professional game forward
here and and speaking of the LPGA Tour
how will this exposure help the women's
game well I think it's it's going to be
significant for the women's game and as
we approach this right cycle we've
placed our broadcast rights with CBS and
NBC our cable rights with with the Golf
Channel and then streaming and starting
in 22 of the ESPN plus we have a
strategic alliance with the LPGA Tour
and as we went into this write cycle we
feel it's very important for our two
organizations and for the game to be
presenting the game both the men's and
women's game on the Golf Channel 24/7
and now CBS's commitment to carry up to
four events for the LPGA Tour is
significant it broadens the reach
time where the women's game like the
men's game has never been as exciting
how do you expand the fan base in an era
when there's so much competition over
media sources and sports I think you
broaden your reach and your broaden your
distribution and that's exactly what
we've done here and you continue to
innovate and evolve in the interests of
the fans so we will be producing a lot
more content that we've than we've ever
produced we have a set of athletes that
are really breaking through and we have
the flexibility to adapt to the market
and so to have these long-standing
partnerships to be able to plan through
2030 to have our tournament schedule in
a really good place allows us to do just
that as we take a look at these crowds
you know the greens shot of everyone
crowded in waiting on the putt
what's the pga doing to prevent it run a
virus spread and that kind of context
well I think we've we've as I said to
others we've basically stood up a
business on the subject we've got a
number of leaders in our company they've
been working on this subject over the
last several weeks and so like others
you have to rely on the CDC the World
Health Organization given the fact that
we play a hundred and seventy-five
tournaments over six tours around the
world you've got to have an
understanding of what's happening on the
ground so we're spending a lot of time
doing that but right now we're all
systems go including this week at The
Players Championship team yeah it really
is doing on hand thank you so much